espn nba reporter and um
and she wrote a dynamite column as a
senior writer
uh at espn.com her podcast work is
second to none
as well ramona shelburne here on the
rich eisen show how are you ramona good
how are you doing rick i am
uh i am well and uh i loved your uh
piece last night even though the subject
matter is nothing to love
but the deep dive um one year
one year ago is when rudy gobert tested
positive for the coronavirus and a bunch
of
oklahoma city thunder fans sitting there
in the building being told to go home
we're kind of looking at each other and
and so did the rest of the country after
all of that what did you glean from your
reporting about
what went down one year ago tonight well
i think what was um
it was kind of amazing is how little we
all
knew back on march 11th you know it's
like you know the governor of oklahoma
kevin fitz essentially said you know we
just had our first
case in oklahoma five days earlier i
mean it really wasn't
widespread it wasn't even in oklahoma
city it was and
it was in uh tulsa and and
it just seemed like a virus like oh you
know everybody was watching it it's
new york it's in l.a it's in san
francisco or something
but it was really um more
uh something that people were just
watching they they didn't realize it
would really come to their
you know doorstep and i think we all had
this
sense um you know when rudy gobert
tested positive like whoa
no and go hearing the first-hand account
from
from the governor from rob hannigan
who's the general manager there in
oklahoma city from adam silver
of we've had a positive test what do we
do
and there's this chilling moment where
clay bennett the owner of the thunder
says uh what's the nba's policy on this
and adam silver and his you know i think
he was on the phone also with his chief
legal counsel
said well what's the state policy and
clay bennett says well i got the
governor right here
and and literally the music is going the
game's about to tip off and they
they have to make this incredible
decision on the fly
right then and the
fortunately they have the good sense to
say okay let's just buy ourselves some
more time
let's just send somebody out there to
tell the officials and the two teams
stop the game until we can figure out
what to do because this is a really big
decision and we got to get it right
and it was like to realize how close
things were to being different where if
the governor had didn't
wasn't at the game that night you know
maybe he's not close enough to talk to
the
to the thunder owner maybe he's on the
phone instead of in a conference room
maybe they don't get word to the thunder
until halftime that night
or maybe they wait till after the game
and then all these other players are
exposed and all these other people are
excited
all of these dominoes that fall and they
felt just right that night at least
um to contain what was obviously a very
dangerous situation
but also this sense of you know
the governor and the the thunder brass
having to make this decision
without a lot of information like is
this airborne
have people in the arena been exposed
how do we tell them to leave without
causing a panic
i mean there was there was somebody who
suggested like should we just pull the
fire alarm
all right no don't do that
it was really it was really a a surreal
moment
of policy making on the fly
that had to be done where adam silver
sitting in this car
the men in oklahoma are making this huge
decision michelle roberts head of the
players union is sitting in an uber
outside her apartment
and major policy affecting thousands of
lies
in the nba that night were made over in
a dizzying series of phone calls in
about 20 or 30 minutes so the most
powerful man in the
in in the nba is like bluetooth to his
car
having this conversation is basically
what we're in the car outside his
apartment
i mean i don't know you got kids i got
kids that's what we do right when we
have
before you walk in it's going to be you
know
right your office on four wheels because
that's the peace and quiet oh my god yes
i know exactly what you're talking about
ramona you know my husband always jokes
like you know he'd be like are you home
yet i'm like i'm in the driveway
my wife susie is the same way ramona
my kids know it's like his mom home yet
oh she's just sitting in the car
you know absolutely making phone calls
and making deals and all that stuff
unbelievable ramona shelburne here on
the rich eisen show speaking to
adam silver though i mean we all i can
hear it in your voice we talked about it
earlier on this show our own
experiences and perspective in the last
year looking back
at what happened one year ago tonight
you know we all have our own
our prism to look at it what about the
commissioner who had to set up a bubble
get that done the bubble as we all know
almost um you know ended because of what
was going on
outside of the bubble with the social
justice
um and then turning around and having a
season
that i put together and they're doing it
in
in in regular um regular season
uh conditions inside of uh arenas albeit
some more empty than others what what is
his
what was he like talking to him about it
a year later well
you know it's interesting his there's
there's there's a positive side of it
right which is
they pulled it off it played 95 percent
of the games
i mean it's right it's not perfect it
people complain about a lot of things
they complain about the all-star game
and they complain about rescheduled
games or playing short-handed but
they've
they're sort of pushed through and
they've done it in a way that feels
safe in a way i mean you know this is
contained
outbreaks where it's dangerous for the
you know certain teams
popped up in in in with certain teams
but then
their protocols are are working enough
to where they can continue on
and it they seem to stem whatever
outbreaks pop up within teams
um but the other thing you know the
commissioner said was
you know there's this concept of shared
sacrifice where
you have to take enough time to get
everybody
on board to say well if our goal is to
continue playing if our goal is to
first to finish the season and resume
the season how do we do that safely
and it may not be perfect it may not be
something that
and any you know a lot of us like even
but if we can do that
you know this is this is how we're going
to have to find a way to do it this
concept of shared sacrifice and
everybody in the league kind of coming
together and
putting aside their individual you know
needs and wants and
you know i mean the players had to be
away from their families for months
right and even now on the road there
they're really just in hotel rooms they
can't leave i mean it's
you know this i can't tell you how many
conversations i have now with league
employees or
somebody who's part of the day-to-day
traveling party who gets tested every
year four times a day etcetera
um it's this this idea that
you know i'll talk to him next time i
see him for testing
like i can't i don't see people every
day that i normally do
and even you know for us like there's so
many teams that come through la where
where i covered you know lakers and
clippers
um and i i i sent a text hey normally
i'd come said i'll
see the game or i'll i'll meet your
coffee beforehand or after nope
there's no meeting up there's no
catching
up except over the phone or a zoom i
mean that's that's all there is
and i think it's this this concept that
if you want to keep going if you want to
you know push forward and live your life
somehow you have to make you have to
have this concept of shared sacrifice
and i think
it's not over i mean we're gonna have to
keep having that you know as the
vaccine rollout comes um of the
of of playing again after if let's say
they you know
let's say once the vaccine has rolled
out and most people have gotten it or
we get something close to hurt immunity
it how long is it gonna take you feel
comfortable
taking off the mask you know i mean it's
not like people are wearing braces
saying i've been vaccinated
i mean yeah it's so it's it's there's
this real
feeling of we are still all in this
together whether you like it or not
and what about the sense again uh was
there
obviously as you're pointing out you've
got positioned people in positions of
power just
making a phone call trying to make a
decision on the fly that is so crucial
so much
on them that that what about the sense
in retrospect that
that the nba played a role of leadership
in this country right i mean that that
because
again for me for me because i do pay
attention to sports and in pop culture
that that when the nba said we're
stopping for 30 days that was like okay
this is real in a way that i don't know
if it really landed
before all that ramona yeah i you know
that was huge
and even the nba was kind of surprised i
mean they like they had had meetings
that they have poor governors call
um where they discuss the option of
playing without fans i mean
i think at the time um
you know in that that was what we were
all thinking and that felt really big
well play a game without fans
wow how's that going to be like right
you know that seemed like a huge thing
and within a minute a matter of hours it
was just completely obsolete
and it was you know even a day or two
before we had we had had um
reporters were no longer going to be in
the locker room that was a big move and
i was like
i don't want to be in there too close
i was already there of like i had been
to the lakers
clippers game on the i think it was the
eighth and i've been to the lakers box
on
on the sixth and i already did not feel
comfortable i was washing my hands every
10 minutes i was going you know
but none of us were wearing baths and we
were all bunched in there
and you know huge crowd you know we call
it the scrum
right it's a big crowd of people around
players and it's just
very tight quarters i mean that was
super dangerous
um and you know we all had gotten to
this place where it was like
yeah we knew this was a big threat we
knew this was a big deal but at the time
there weren't
there were cases but it wasn't didn't
seem like it was everywhere lurking
behind anything
um and like it does now and you know i
don't think we have ever had even a
consciousness about masks
right you know so that i wrote a story
and we also did a podcast it's a 30-30
podcast that's also
um out that kind of tells the oral
history of it and um
you know at that point
it's amazing all the things that
happened on march 11th but dr fauci had
testified before congress and somebody
asked a question about professional
sports
and even at that moment he said well i
think they should think about playing
without fans
and uh one of my colleagues you know
jeff silgat and mark medina they
have a story in usa today today which
talks about you know the deputy
commissioner mark tatum
um heard that statement and that landed
with him
really deeply like whoa okay we should
play with our fans
but you know in my conversation with the
commissioner he essentially said
you know at that moment we you know
no public health official had said you
have to stop the games
like we weren't even to that place and
so now you look back on it you're like
of course they should have stopped the
games what were we all thinking like
that should have been two weeks earlier
even because you know as we found out
pretty quickly there was a
there were several other players in the
nba who were positive teams who had
played either the jazz or had picked it
up
elsewhere um i know a lot of people had
picked it up in mar
early march but it was uh
it was a it was an it was a a crazy
revel you know a crazy
moment day and then and by the way do
you remember march 11 what also happened
that that
that morning tom hanks tom hanks tom
hanks i mean
lots of things happened on march 11th
one year ago
that was the day it wasn't just sports
that came crashing down it was like
that was the day that like everything
did
that that coveted became very real for
everyone and i
i always flash back on what um you know
earlier in that week we'd all been
hearing you know this
some of the public health officials who
said you know if you if you're thinking
about shutting down soon and when you
should do it
the answer is yes do it now do it
yesterday
because every day that goes by that you
haven't shut down is another day that
this virus is exponentially growing your
community
and i don't think we understood what
that meant until march 11th
ramona great peace great um piece of
reporting and
i appreciate the call let's do this in a
couple weeks when we're we're talking
about the game
i really appreciate it thank you for the
call ramona yeah you're welcome
it's ramona shelburne espn.com go check
it out
what a heck of a piece